all right guys it's happening we're
doing a tattoo based off a rumor ready y
yep
[Music]
a this is my first tattoo and I feel
like this is a bad idea for this to be
my first tattoo there's no rrats right
now dude can't go
[Music]
back W oh my gosh and I'm Nick Nick
what's your name nice to meet you I am a
little optimistic that this is going to
be the Gateway for me to get tattoos but
I don't want to be here neither does
Steve look at Steve I'm just here to get
paid nice to meet you yeah Sunny nice to
meet you how you doing Steve how you
doing we're here to buy more woo dude
let's go bab hey hey yo let's
[__] baby [__] go it's about to
happen dude W baby about to happen baby
it's about to happen baby and this got
hell mosquito B in Vegas I actually
moved to avoid this [__] but but Bill
Gates is making mosquitoes I guess over
in Vegas I [__] up and went outside in
Las Vegas for like 30 minutes that's
what you get for living by a body of
water that's what you get for buying
property someone like barquin lies to
you he says there's no mosquitoes in Las
Vegas yeah okay guess what there
actually are a hell of mosquitoes in Las
Vegas dude so you're moving back he's
moving
back he's moving back did you notice I
shaved the wrong [__] leg too oh you
did yeah cuz I pre-shaped like was left
so did I we are men of our word so um
we're getting the tattoos done that we
promised the uh JK audience we were
going to do if we were still around a
year later I don't think I would have
ever bailed on it because I like the
joke of it a lot and I like the fact
that we share something real that's off
camera I think that's actually uh Jokes
Aside like that means a lot to me but if
Nick bailed I would bail [__] we're
going right man oh you guys suck [__]
your mosquito bites you just had to have
the crazy pepperoni mosquito bites on
dude they just got me so good in Vegas
of all places in Vegas it's going to
hurt like a [__] huh nice and smooth
like a skinless raw chicken breast yeah
it can't wait to show my mom can't wait
to show my mom my mom would be like I'm
not tell my mom [__] I'm not jaanese
killed your grandparents right huh my
grandfather if he was alive and he knew
I was getting a Japanese he's turning in
his grave right now what did I do it all
for that's what he'd say what did I do
it all for and like I was already p but
this is another level I'm like bounce
this a light
bounce does anybody even remember like
who started the idea in the first place
we was just talking about that like who
started it I don't even remember if we
survive one more year should we all get
fear everyone tattoos absolutely this
sounds like the worst idea we've ever
are we down I'm
in I'm the hairiest one here I think I
was the hairest one oh really you're
the closest I've ever been
hereis he should be I'm [__] Fried
Chicken bro we brought my tattoo in we
got the homies Andy sunny and man coming
out here from both the alhamra and the
Huntington Beach Shop they came and
agreed to tattoo this when I told Andy
my boy the story he's a guy who did a
lot of the Kindra tattoos and stuff when
I told him the story and I sent him
Bart's photo he wanted to verify with
his Japanese homie and he was like all
right just to make sure this says fear
anybody in bad Japanese grammar and I
was like that's the one and now they're
here they drove to the office they set
up shop in here we moved all of our
regular shooting tables and they
literally are about to tattoo all six of
us with this incorrect grammar fear
everyone tattoo so Joe's messing with
Bart trying to make him think that Nick
actually isn't here I'm going to say
yeah bar things Nick's not here bar
things Nick's not here yeah all right
dude he's asking us to call him I told
him Nick's not answering
I'm saying his phone go I said his phone
goes
to we're adding so much detail a lot of
info hey if if you said his phone goes
voice let it ring once and then hang up
so he knows that you're actively hanging
up on it do not distur we never we never
provide that much answers to anything
yeah ever ever we're all working
together to find him all I know is I Ain
going first I know how this [__]
trick works dude it's better that you're
not going first they use cuz I want to
go first and
go like Ryan are you okay hey everybody
we need a joint consultation on this go
oh that looks dope right
here Nick Nick where you Nick come here
damn dude this is tight can you go
around my bug bites and like change the
language I don't care if it I don't care
if CH damn that's big dude that's going
to look huge on my leg bro I know an
idiot D don't point at me laugh me so B
already
knowbody dude I swear to God Bart is
smaller than that he just looks he makes
it look small is Bart smaller than that
or is his leg just big no Bart has
childlike legs his legs are pretty small
they get muscular his child siiz legs
but they're
[Music]
muscular dud nowhere to be found nowhere
nowhere we're going to we're just going
to do it I just drove in right now yeah
we're just going to do it maybe he shows
up man are we doing inside [__] yeah
it's much smaller is there a way to
mimic this one no no yours going to be
two different sizes what no that's so
[__] up if Nick doesn't show up should
we kick him out yeah what's Nick's
punishment he's out I have no idea at
least a month suspect did you call a
month what does that what does that
really say about his character and his
loyalty to us and by the way for years I
said you can't tou those ears but he
also hasn't texted
do any guys have Tiff's number
or well either way we don't have that
this this may be more see-through yeah
all right oh that's for sure more
see-through yeah your job thanks TR it
correctly hey Nick purple yeah what's up
are you going to come to the office what
do you mean shootings
tomorrow what do you mean what do I mean
what are we doing today we're all
getting tattoos everyone's here N I
thought you guys were doing a
bit the tattoo I didn't know we were
really doing it are we really doing
it where the [__] are you
bro can you just tell Bart that I'm not
going to make it can you just tell him
for me please this is so lame tell you
how lame this is man we're all here by
the way Anthony set this all up he
actually did a good job for a change he
actually set all this [__] up he got all
these tattoo artists here we're all here
dude we're all here and you're not it's
[__] lame
dude I don't care I don't care just come
just get your ass down here then if
you're sorry all right later [__] you he
coming he said he's
coming have you seen Steve's right leg
it's nothing about mosquito bikes oh
[__] how you the mosquito bik dude check
this out bar some us this [__] it's
[__] heavy yeah it's heavy all look
take this [__] out dude what the [__]
Che
this you think I to show up
[__] you want to show yeah I thought
you [__] you dude they put me in a box
for
this we had in there for 4
hours you want to test my dedication
dude it's so stupid you got me dude cuz
the whole time when I was driving after
I I was like wait I was like Nick's one
of the most downest dudes cuz he fights
people for a living oh I don't I don't
would he like fny dude that was so good
who do you think's going to take it the
worst right there this
guy because he doesn't even know the
feeling and when you don't know what the
feeling is like I think he's in his head
you know like he's probably
overestimating it and uh this is my
prediction I think at first he'll be
like oh it's not that bad and then as
he's going he's like ah it's it's kind
of burning yeah I feel like he would say
[__] like that every tattoo artist
always recommends that you don't drink
alcohol both before and after because
the way it thins your blood but we don't
play by the rules and we're going during
so here we go cheers to stupid T guys
don't do it un cheers to the
rules what's the worst that could happen
so this is a cool like kind of small
world where Andy is Anthony's tattoo
artist and my tattoo which is the shop
that uh Andy's from all of those guys
I've known them for like 20 years
because fun story when I was going out
there trying to learn how to do tattoos
and stuff their boss Jess he did my very
first tattoo right here and so this is a
really cool meaningful time because like
not only did I get my first tattoo from
those guys but I'm going to be getting
this careful boy tattoo with everybody
and it's from the same team we all went
to the same high school man B and me
tell us again what you heard about bart
when he was in school he's cool buff
strong no you didn't say that you say
nerd I guess nerds rob houses these
days got to have your pocket protector
on while you're jumping over a fence all
right guys to commemorate this special
moment we got some oh [__] fear everyone
merch Y how sick is that dude and you
can get this you can get this right now
you could get it and you can get a whole
bunch of other careful boy merch just
click the link in the description box
below and we got one of every size let's
wear this while we get the tattoos
today anti that's so tight you guys plan
this the whole time y it's like we're
joining the game for the first time this
is Brotherhood guys it's available now
get it now the fact that we have careful
boys merch is actually stunning yeah
this is dope right I've never been part
of a gang before get ready save your
money we're going to have a bunch of
different careful boy shirts JK news all
that stuff it's like really dope and
then you actually pay attention to read
it you're like what the [__] maybe maybe
my kids shouldn't know this lesson but
this is cool all right guys it's
happening the time is now it we're men
of our word where we said if we cross to
well actually we weren't really meant on
our word they kept reminding us aren't
you guys supposed to get the tattoos
when you cross a million we're like [__]
you guys [__] remember but because
you remember now we're the men of our
can someone remind us who had this idea
of matching tattoos I don't think if we
remember why we're doing it we said we
will get it if we survive a year oh yeah
yeah yeah we're doing a tattoo based off
a rumor BART to be fair he's going to
get double of the same one yeah cuz I
can't just keep the original we're ready
to [__] ready to go and we got our
buddies here from my tattoo
y we keep promises so let's do
[Music]
it oh wow oh [__] let's go dude I
haven't done tattoos in so long years
ready yep yep the sink in the bathroom
okay
yeah ah
[__] man dude I can't tell if you're
being serious or not it hurts so bad
dang machine's really changed over the
years huh yeah man oh Nick you you are
going to love
this yo this actually Joe you're right
it feels like different I'm the source
tattoo that They're copying off of I
have a couple other tattoos so my wife I
just sent her a picture on the way here
I drove here straight from Vegas Anthony
sent me a picture of all the tattoo
equipment set up I said that to her
she's like you guys are the dumbest men
on Earth and I was like I think that's
the name of our new show this originally
was a mistake I revealed on JK news we
Google translated thought it would be
something hard ended up being a mistake
and most people try not to repeat their
mistakes but now everyone wants to redo
the mistake so I'm going to have two of
the exact same thing
so this is going to be [__] stupid I
bet Gio's watching this right now
thinking I'm glad I left at the right
time Sunny's really good so I think it's
like it actually feels really nice
getting a tattoo it just feels like
you're getting a shot at the doctor's
over and over again uh it's it just
feels like a very repetitive pain that
you think you're going to get used to
and you kind of don't and then sometimes
you start passing out depending on where
you're getting it done but overall it's
completely bearable I don't think
there's any reason to be afraid of it
but don't be like us and make stupid
promises that you have to keep ever
since then I'm like trying really hard
to not say anything that will lead to
another one of these episodes Sunny if
you get Nick can you just jab the [__]
out it's his first one it has to hurt
and then just try to set a speed record
everyone can bribe me and I'll do
whatever the win y love can you just
like try to do nck as fast as
possible
what is that is it just no it's just
this company dude Nick's going to love
this you know what's funny when uh Ryan
first tagged Us online on IG right uh
about this story about the fact that we
were going to get these tattoos I tagged
Nina on Instagram post in the captions
and I was like n's going to be pissed
Ryan responds back on that comment with
the JK news Instagram account and he
says pissed or jealous and then she
responds to that comment and puts C
socks jealous now I think she didn't
think this thing through I think she was
trying to be all like charming and funny
online and then I set the appointment
with these guys all right to make it
actually official and I'm like yo on
this day we're going to go do this and
suddenly she's like wait you're going to
for real do this and I'm like um you're
the one who was on IG saying that you
was jealous about it so we're going to
do it I was like you shouldn't have done
that and now I have to [__] do it
she's like no if you want me to if you
want me to rec comment and say this is a
bad idea I could do it I was like no no
no no no no I'm man of my word so we
have to do this so I can't back out and
now I'm going to forever if I get
questioned especially by her family or
anything be like she supported this from
day one and that's why she's down for me
if Nick didn't actually show up for this
what would you have done
realistically I'm firing him I would
lose a lot of respect to be honest I'll
be like [__] you dude no no [__] you
I'll be like you're a bit I would like
cuz Nick to me is like a down ass hard
ass [__]
and then and then I'm going to be like
oh that's the reason why he lost all
those fights exactly when he get pushed
to the edge he Buck that's why he's a
knockout artist yeah
yeah it's more about the uh why we're
doing this that's what I'm here for
everything else is sort of a beautiful
tapestry of like you know niess but the
why we're doing this the fact that we
survived when everyone thought we
wouldn't I I could
not put that on my body so you not bul
clean I hope
[Music]
so about to do some traditional Japanese
style uh with no machine it's just
straight pokey poke what's it what's it
called teal tabori
yeahi we go
no oh my God how does that feel Anthony
it actually is like more painful but
it's less consistent is it is it as
accurate as the gun though no yeah the
the traditional or the machine one
you're consistently feeling this thing
whereas this one it's like more painful
and then there's that pause and then
pain PA yeah but I've always wanted to
do this and try it just to know how it
feels wow look at that
wow it kind of feels appropriate though
we're doing like Japanese characters
yeah but it's incorrect
Japanese yes very swag very nice hello
oh so my wife Hanah to my wife my wife
is in the chat
yes man really
good your wife my wife she's laughing at
me filled with
regret hold on we're afraid of everybody
we're we're trembling we look like
stupid ass [__]
Grooms you don't
groom yeah that's true matching shirts
matching shirts stupid groom ran fell
asleep he did a really good job yo kind
of looks hard bro yeah it looks hard you
should take a picture of this how many
people you think this belongs
to dude what the [__] [__] we actually
did it hey which one's no cheese
we damn let's go thank you Sunny almost
there almost Nick let's go Nick I'm
ready I'm not even shaking so do I just
let it air out Let it bleed out okay you
got tatted right here why are you
bleeding right here that's [__] weird
no that's to let you know there's jelly
in that
donut looks like you guys are like at
ComiCon could be the same character or
something and there's part leg too
that's [__]
crazy it's like 18 mosquito P hey [__]
you man look tight with WRA not without
it everyone's all about like hey these
days you need to be self- loved you need
to care what's more s self love than to
be best friend matching tattoos with
your own
leg why you making that face I'm just
thinking about how stupid it
[Music]
is Howes it feel
Stevie [__] cake
huh got any last words [__] someone
saved me dude I'm ready baby I'm ready
be gentle please hey go like
[Music]
super feel like what you feel like like
a hurts
dude like it hurts that [__] looks like
she's [__] trying to eradicate a
tumor I'm going to just try to stay calm
so don't make me [__] laugh that's
tight filthy bear bought another badge
that's another
one an bought a badge an I can't even
name them
all guys buy some badges if you want if
you want Anthony to leave kjas and just
stay with J Leave kjas Your Allegiance
how many badges do they need for you to
leave K probably like three probably
like you know like a merch order no it
doesn't feel like anything and I
remember coming down the escalator my
best friend pulled my pant leg up hey
Mrs look your son a tattoo and he just
broke it to her right there and I was
like oh [__] I wasn't ready for that but
she was like why why you do that like
[Music]
that what's the next tattoo that you're
going to get unfortunately probably when
rack up this place lasts longer than it
should I to get clean would do an old
enough for kisses
in the movie The beg which I introduced
to this place and uh yeah became Legend
and like for me to do the twi with
tattoo a dude I'm I'm tired of lowball
on you guys I'll do it at 3 million it
feels good actually it's kind of nice H
it feels great I thought I was going to
hurt more honestly just cuz he's [__]
jabbing it for pain it's like a six five
or six you know I kind of I kind of
liked it though cuz it is a roller
coaster of emotions a little bit like
all jokes aside you do feel like a
little nervous and then when it starts
to happen you're like oh [__] this is
unlike anything I've ever felt before
definitely not the most comfortable but
it's not unbearable I can see why people
do this are you going to get like a
jistic tattoo after this you know what I
don't know I probably got to get my
wife's name tattooed first cry [__]
on my neck dog my advice to taica as a
father that has two stupid tattoos Live
Your Life in a way [__] that
doesn't make sense
it sounds very wise that's my wife
texted me and I was like she goes this
is my least favorite thing you've ever
done who said
that is it even cool looking I can't
believe you're doing
this now I'm Hur hey look at Bart's legs
right now dude oh my god god dude no way
no way Bart you're weird
bro hey Bart how about just say no
yo this is so cool I got blood dripping
out of my Saran R I don't think I'm
going to bleed you are I think I'm too
tough too tough I think I'm just too
tough someone that doesn't know us is
going to look at it and go wait what the
[__] it's Bart's leg hey isn't that
China panes isn't that China panes
that's China panes too Chan everyone got
a China panes here hey this CH got two
CH panes I I wouldn't have it anyway
honestly you're the man I appreciate you
so much you're you're the
man [__] did it the careful boys have
gotten the fear everyone official tattoo
to match Bart's stupidity and we could
not have done it without the amazing
tattoo artist from my tattoo both in
alhamra and Huntington Beach we got Andy
we got sunny and we got man hey man
thank you all so much for coming through
and just putting ridiculous on our lives
for the rest of our lives we couldn't
have done this without you we love you
all so much so appreciate it everybody
if you want to get some professional ink
done make sure you hit up their shop and
the IG is my tattoo and piercing check
them out y'all and if you want to get
the same one they've done it six times
already it gets better and better
everything it
is can you my first tattoo
[Music]
brely
like like